uh  [Applause]  i'm done  listening to you morgan  everyone has everyone tried it your way  and look what happened  [Music]  face the truth morgan  you failed  and now  it's my turn  i'm gonna do what you couldn't i'm gonna  rebuild the world  i'm gonna help everyone that you let  down  all while you watch from the outside  you should rebuild the world victor you  should help people but if i hear that is  not what you're doing if i hear that  you've heard anybody that i care about i  swear to god  i will come for you victor  and i will do what you tried to do to me  on that submarine  only i will miss  felicia  she'll find this place  she'll get through to you no she won't  she won't have anything to do with me  after this  you